You are listening to radiolab, radiolab from
W and Y.
S. T. E. N. P. R. A. I'm Jana, boom rotten. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab podcast. And before we get to the podcast part of the podcast,
we should just say that Robert and I, by the time you hear this,
we're going to be like seconds away from the beginning of our live show tour.
It is called apocalyptical. Yeah, it's like apocalypse on an elliptical.
It's how I like to think of it. It's got monsters and explosions, great stories,
great musicians. Glen Coachy, Darren Grey, Sarah it lip state.
Amazing comedians. Uh, depending on the city you might see Reggie Watts,
Simon AmSteel, Kurt Braunohler. Oh, fear Eisenberg, Patton Oswald.
And we're going to be performing in 21 cities.
And the first show was in Hartford, Connecticut. Yes.
Wednesday of the week that this podcast comes out in Thursday of that week,
we're going to be in Hartford, Connecticut.
I remember we go from city to city to city,
to city to city during the months of October and November. Yeah.
And you can find out what cities we're going to begin.
And what time is we're gonna be there and how to buy the tickets at
radiolab.org/live okay. Now the podcast,
take it away. Kay. It's something you do every day.
You don't think about it very much, but when you do it in New York City,
strange things happen.
What is he at? What are you talking about? I don't know. It's a teeth, but my,
are you going to tell me what it is? Well,
I can tell you that it all started with this guy. I'll go with this.
That's good writer who's been on the show a few times. I'm Fredrick Kaufman,
the author of at the farm. How food stopped being food.
We brought him in to tell us a story about the human gut.
This was a while back member this year.
It was during the occupy Wall Street protest,
so you know I've been occupying Wall Street for about 30 years now.
Fred actually lives right near Wall Street and somebody took a shit right on my
doorstep the other morning. Really? Yeah.
I had an occupy Wall Street Turd on my doorstep. How do you know that?
It wasn't, you know, some right wing and could have been a tea party Turd.
It could've been a tea party Turd. I sent it to the lab for an hour.
The blue as opposed to red and this whole a poop on the stoop story.
This reminds me of a whole other series of stories that it sent Fred off on a,
on a significant rant. You know, you don't,
you don't get the even the beginning of what's going on here about poop
[inaudible]. So
Fred told us that the first thing we had to do about North River sewage
treatment plan was we had to go to North River wastewater treatment plan.
Go there, crossover.
It's just over on the upper west side in Manhattan usually.
How often do you come here? So our producer, Pat Walters and I,
we went up there. Yeah, included in this intention. I don't know.
Walter's just muscled his splay into position two years. Again,
why are you doing, anyway, we went up there and we ended up talking to this guy,
Steve [inaudible]. Robert, Hey rob, how are you? I've never, she like,
yeah, he's like the,
I've been on camera before and Superintendent of the planet NYC,
Steve is basically the eliminator.
He eliminates a very significant portion of New York City's boop. We have it.
I think it's really neat jobs sooner. The glory of this position.
It's pretty exciting because again,
you really get to see this kid Steve at the beginning of a process that I think
we all kind of know the outline of,
but the details and the places that New York City's poop in particular end up
taking you are truly astonishing.
So the first thing that we learned is that in New York City,
this whole wastewater treatment thing,
it happens on an almost unbelievable scale and gallows about citywide,
about 1.3 billion gallons every, every single day.
That 7.45 pounds per gallon, that's, you know,
7 billion pounds. Wow.
Which is actually more than the weight of all the elephants on the planet. What?
Yes. We counted, we know we interviewed the elephant,
but until 1986 we dumped pretty much all of it into the ocean or straight into
the Hudson river. 1986 and that's like yesterday, you know,
and can imagine a west side of Manhattan before 1986 all the sewage went into
the river. Unprocessed, unprocessed, went straight into the river and treated.
That blows my mind. Yeah. It was not a good situation.
But by 1986 the city had built several treatment plants, including this one,
which happens to be the biggest,
it's a very impressive building with trees on top and soccer fields.
And I watched it get built. It's right near my neighborhood.
So kids played soccer, that player, they played soccer on top of the poo place.
Did you have any sense of what lies inside that building? No,
I had no,
no. We're going to walk in according to the process. All right.
And then in the walking tours I've had of New York City,
this beats everything.
Yeah. That we're going to Andrew through the doors. Mark Exit.
That's always a good way.
So imagine parkland on top and a kind of open framework.
Sort of like a parking garage and word like up on the top level with the
treatment plant itself underneath us.
And Steve Walks us over to this manhole cover, opened it up.
Hey Aaron, look down and see ya. And we looked down.
That's where the water comes in. Well, below the highways.
I mean there's this river river of everything is this broiling brown tore it way
below us.
The vitamin a channel is a hundred feet down to the first thing Steve has to do
is like be headed up out of there.
We pumped it up a hundred feet and it cascades down through the rest of the
process. Ultimately back to the ribbon and at this point it becomes
um,
series of waterfalls
like Viagra. Yeah, that's exactly right.
Warren. Down below us through this eight story staircase of pools,
almost like Charisse lakes, we go high.
That is each point a processes Loa and each pool has its own job.
Starting from the top,
there's like one room where they just skim the oil off the surface. Fats,
oils and greases float to the top and we skim them off. Sewage flows down again.
So we're going to walk down this envelope. Warm is wide open space.
This is impressive. This. This feels the big long gallery here. Yeah,
like a huge rectangular lake. Our Lake. Okay. That's correct.
A warm sewage. So if the air temperature is cold enough,
the vapor condenses on the cold concrete and it rains inside the building.
If it's really cold range and drips, call or whatever,
it condenses and comes down and droplets.
That's the definition of rain and it's all be soaking wet in here cause it's
raining and if it's really cold,
that vape of freezes and we'll have snow on the floor. All right.
Real climate. Meanwhile, in the lake,
the sludgy stuff kind of settles down to the bottom,
settles out and get sent along down to another layer to the next step.
And as you go down deeper and deeper,
eventually you get to this one broom that's like weirdly kind of beautiful.
It had a kind of dome like top and they were,
there was a big pond in front of yours. It's frothy, it's a lie.
Kind of Nice like Tan colored to it.
The pond was brimming with life becomes a biological process.
One that is spookily similar to what happens in our own stomach,
we heat it to 98 degrees. Low and behold,
it's coming from humans and this is where they add a bunch of bacteria to the
sewage does show which is actually food to this bacteria and then Steve adds
other bacteria to eat those bacteria.
The ash it form is eat the complex proteins and carbohydrates and the method
formers eat them. The acid formers and cannibal fest, everyone's eating,
everything's eating, everything go from bug and now this bacteria,
they were little mayflies and bugs calling on the surface and everywhere around
the room. They were enormous deletions of spiders.
They're all over the place. I received them. The images,
images eat the sludge, the spiders eat the meat.
You said if this was an outdoor plant, we had birds eating the spiders.
It's a whole ecosystem and it's exactly see, right,
so well York City has its waste treatment plant,
a rain forest filled with animals,
but of course the product of all this. Oh, through that door. What do you says?
Discuss? It's so bad.
I just want to smell more of it because what you've left with is this thick soup
of like super concentrated to it. Right. How much do you smell?
You smell it on mouth. Yeah. Oh No, it smells. Let's get out of here.
I smell it. Yeah, hold on. Once you have that soup, you take that.
We put it through a Santa fuge where we mechanically spin it as salad spinner.
Whoa.
It's kind of like the spin cycle in your washing machine and it basically sweats
out all the additional moisture and what I'm left with is I got real
concentrated like 30% solids, moist soil,
a ton of it.
There's 125 million gallons of it and if you want to like try to picture that in
your mind. I did a that much sludge.
That's what this stuff is called would fill the rose bowl.
I'm not even a football fan,
but just like picture a big college football stadium filled with this
concentrated sewage sludge and that's what Steve's left with at the end of every
single day. Which leads to the obvious question. What do I do with that stuff?
Um, all right. I'll go ahead and place the microphone.
This is where the story takes a really strange turn.
This is where things got a little, how would you put it? A little emotional.
Emotional. Mike, can you hear me? Yeah, I can hear you.
Ended up tracking down this guy named Mike. Mike Sharp,
who's hired to answer this question like what do we do with New York City is
processed sewage sludge.
He says for awhile they hauled it 103 miles out in the ocean and dumped it just
like before,
but eventually what happened was in 1988 the government banned all ocean
disposal of waste and because New York City had been dumping so much of this
stuff in the ocean for so long, the EPA said,
not only do you have to stop dumping in the ocean,
you have to find something good to do with some of it. Beneficial.
Where use of biosolids is our sewage Guy Steve again, and he says,
you can use this sludge as fertilizer can use as fertilizer.
Steve told us that lots of cities do this.
You can go to home depot and buy a bag of middle organizer.
Middle organized is biosolids familiar walking.
So when you buy a bag of Malloy orgonite and spread it over your tomatoes,
you're actually using treated poop from the people of Milwaukee.
They've marketed it for a retail sale,
and this is basically where Mike comes in. It was his job to sell our sludge.
So off I went. Is this like a thing? He does, yeah.
He'd done it in other places for other towns,
but this time start spreading the new,
it didn't go the way it usually does.
He doesn't remember exactly who he approached first,
but state Alabama after state,
Ohio after state in the ANA said No.
I can read number one state. I won't even mention who, but you know,
the comment was made, you're not going to get in New York City here.
Don't even think about it.
There were talented to accept biosolids from every city in the planet except New
York City, Texas, Oklahoma, Arkansas, Alabama.
We don't want New York City biosolids like ours is.
We don't want cities like a biosolids. The objections were all over the map.
The floods will have toxins in it or disease or like who knows? You know,
it'll have the city in it even though technically when they tested it,
it was no different than the sludge from anywhere else. It's the same stuff.
But I wanna know over Kansas and over again in Kentucky.
And here's the same thing.
Don't think you're ever going to get New York City permitted here.
I feel a little [inaudible].
I haven't even lived here that long and I'm feeling so it's um,
your residency in New York, it's such a collective effort here.
You know that there was a prejudice against New York City versus almost any
other sludge in the country. And as you mentioned that a certain point,
Mike started offering to give this stuff away for free and still nobody wants it
until it was kind of an just one of those flukes of life.
You got to Colorado. Uh, I got lost coming out of the airport.
Huge thunderstorm. I thought I was going north,
ended up going south and all of a sudden he's about 75 miles east of Denver.
You have, you have pretty far south. Like I said,
I was lost in a big thunderstorm in winter. The first down I find a hotel,
so anyway,
next morning down to the coffee shop gets to talking with some guy and telling
him I've got all of this sludge New York City and I just want to put it on a
train and bring it out to the farms in Colorado.
Bonds is you're going to do what? Typical reaction.
You're going to put something from New York City on a rail car and haul it all
the way here, but then he paused and said, keep talking.
And we talked about the concept and before Mike knew it,
he'd found a place that would accept New York city's unwanted sludge
fertilizers, fertilizer. That plant doesn't care what it comes from.
This is Wayne Wayne Scholtz.
He ended up running the operation in Colorado or track out there would hold 17
train cars
and this is how the New York City poop train began.
A couple of days before Earth Day,
1992 several thousand tons of New York City sludge left the big apple headed for
Lamar, Colorado, 1600 miles away.
But it wasn't exactly an immediate success.
Well, I think a whole thing started out pretty small.
Initially there was just three or four farms that were using it.
This guy's one of the first farmers to start using it. Sure.
My name's John Stope intensives. He remembers early on,
public was invited to come out and comment on what they thought about the
biosolids and it conjured up some very strong emotions.
One person said something that they were concerned if any of this got spilled
out of the trucks transporting it onto the highway,
that it would probably eat a hole in the asphalt and had to be treated like a
nuclear disaster site.
And there were people who said their horse had died from biosalts.
I never heard the horror story, but I can tell you one about a cow. You know,
I think it's typical that people are always suspicious of something that's from
far away.
There was a salsa commercial about that time.
I cook him off a Connie sauce, the cowboys, uh,
through the cookout camp basically cause they were upset because the salsa he
was serving was made in New York City. New York
get a rope and that's kind of how it was.
But then pharmacy we were using it started to notice that it was kind of
awesome.
I remember going to a farmer's field not long after he'd started using the
biosolids. The previous wheat crop was 40 Bushel.
After using the [inaudible]
66 bushel wheat,
the scrapping increased by a third and you never hear a 66 Bushel.
John says they started to notice other little things about it too.
We had a lot of trouble with an aphid called the Russian wheat Aphid,
but we saw an interesting thing with a couple of neighbors east of me.
When they put the biosolids in their field,
it kept the aphids away and wasn't just eight minutes.
We have a big prairie dog problem out here.
One farmer told Wayne when he put the biosolids in this field,
they packed up and lived across to the neighbor and he thought it was a human
scent. And as word got out, Winston started getting calls from all over.
The county will put me on the list, put me on the list. I wanted some of that.
There was a waiting list because as the New York City biosolids had gained
acceptance in Colorado, other states that started picking them up too.
I had a list of 50 farmers and wanting the product and after a few years they
were getting a train load pretty much every week the most in a month sometimes
too. It was 153 drinkers.
It's quite that much stick with ebb and flow depending on the flow of the
biosolids but makes sense.
On average we covered maybe 10,000 acres a year and we had enough demand to
cover,
I mean farmer demand that we could easily cover 50 to 75,000 acres a year
and here is what I think is the most amazing part of this whole story.
You take it from Lake John who accounts for a big chunk of those acres.
John's growing wheat. Yes,
the hard red winter wheat and the wheat goes primarily into bread type of
products. A lot of bread type products with a pound of wheat. Rough.
Just rule of thumb is you get about a loaf of bread and if you do some quick
math, he said you'd get about 2000 pounds of wheat from each acre that you farm.
So that's 2000 loaves of bread per acre times the 10,000 acres that the
biosolids were on. So you just keep Ng Roche. And so we're up into the,
around 20 million loaves of bread or something like that. And that's each year.
So we're talking hundreds of millions of loaves of bread, which means don says,
you may well have eaten a slice of bread that had a grain or two of wheat come
from our farm and to like in some small but very real sense,
that's a slice of bread that we helped make with the stuff that we like make
biosolids from New York come from the bread that they ate, that uh,
went into their sewer system and end up in the wastewater treatment plant and
ended up in Colorado. And then, uh, you know, the cycle begins again.
[inaudible].
It was the ultimate and recycling. This is a magical thing. That's Fred again,
the writer from the beginning of the story, it's really going from,
from the straight line,
make it go away and never return to a circle.
The end is in the beginning.
[inaudible]
I was and by it turns out that's not the end of the story.
Since I turned off utilities and locked the doors a couple weeks ago,
we sent a reporter
out to Colorado to hang out with Wayne.
All I'm seeing here is a bunch of empty buildings. These are our buildings.
Empty everything, shut down, everything shut down and when she found, wow,
it's that the circle had become a straight line again.
At least I could have shown that one. It was an operation.
Winter did that for a long time. Things were great at one time.
Summer Oh seven I had 26 employees,
everybody hopping and it was slowly New York had come in and Oh,
you've got to cheapen up your prize.
You got somebody else who do this cheaper and the economy prices,
the diesel field, the railroad cost of transportation,
just slowly it got down to floor for employees and myself and all they have to
do is send you a 30 day written notice and your contracts gone.
That's how it happened. But you know everything's bottom line.
I remember the last day or last load, which you happen to be 20 years,
the day of our first load showing up,
our first load showed up on Earth Day 1992 and our last load showed up April
22nd, 2012 and we sat there and watched the last load.
And you spread it across the farm ground there?
Yeah, they have asked me if,
if something happens,
would I be interested in managing it and I tore stole them. Yes.
But I'm not sitting around holding my breath.
Well New York does with it now. They go to landfills,
they mix it with garbage and they buried in landfills.
I gotta say it's kind of sad to come in here and see it now. Nothing
[inaudible]
wait, hold on a second.
I mean I obviously feel for Wayne and all those people who lost their jobs,
but it sounds, it sounded to me a little nuts from the beginning that we would,
what are our bio, whatever it's called on the,
on a train and put it all the way to Colorado. That's,
that must cost a lot of money. Yeah, it's Kinda nuts.
It's costing like millions of dollars and we've always put some of it in the
landfill.
It's just that now we put about half of it into landfill and half of it into
like abandoned strip mines and none of it goes to Colorado. But, well, how,
how much wood are we saving by not getting it on trains and sending it across
the country or what's well like, so according to Mike and Wayne,
it's about half as expensive to put it in a landfill as it was to send it to
Colorado, which sounds like a lot, but if you add it up, if you add up the,
of sending all of this stuff that we were sending in Colorado and you add up the
cost of the landfill and you do the subtraction and you divide it across like
let's just say like 8 million people, it cost,
it would cost you Robert Krulwich about 25 cents a month to send it back.
That's it. Quarter for quarter. God, that's nothing.
I would have expected the answer to be a lot more than that.
Me To come on New York, do the right thing.
Can we store our own pride, integrity, you know,
integrity in the fields of Colorado here, we could close the circle again,
close the circle.
[inaudible]
well, usually Jen, Robert would say thank you and we'll see you next time.
But they're not here because they're on tour.
You can find more information about the tour at radiolab.org/live thanks for
listening.